we were traveling this week and we were
renting a car
and
the people sitting at the car desk at
the hertz or where we budgeted where we
were
they looked um
i felt for them they they looked bored
they did not look fulfilled in their job
um they're lovely to us for sure um
but it just
it hit me that that job's probably going
to get automated sooner rather than
later um
given that they didn't look like they
were using every second of their time
and all the incentives are going that
way and we haven't talked about
automation in a while so you just went
to a conference on this so tell us uh
anything cool you saw and then we'll
dive in a little deeper the conference
was fascinating um there were a few
takeaways i had
the first is that ai is advancing and
getting more powerful and practical
there was a company for example that was
an ai education company where they
monitor your eye movements and facial
movements to see if you get bored
during the lesson and then if you are
bored they like switch tax or do
something that like you know reactivates
you i should get one of those for our
conversations on this podcast what are
you saying bro when you get bored with
whatever that when i get laurier yeah or
vice versa like i don't need zach i need
ai's out there zach you'll be like hey
hey hey i see you all right i'm out of
it
so cow so ai imagine that yeah there's
an art to sleeping when your teacher's
not looking when you're in you know
middle school high school right put your
head down yeah apparently and i can see
through that [ __ ] geez that sucks uh and
it's meant to help you engage more yeah
theoretically better right um but it's
getting better and stronger and more
practical so that that's one takeaway
uh another takeaway i had was that its
job replacement capacity
is growing and that's
hand in hand with some of the things
you're describing in the labor market so
we're in the midst of a fairly nasty
cycle which is you look up and say hey
you're short workers well like then
let's automate the the jobs that are
there and then you need fewer workers
then you have fewer workers i mean right
now we're still down last i checked
about four million jobs since
pre-covered
and the labor force participation rate
in the united states right now is maybe
61.9 percent something really low
if you look at the international
comparables i think we're tied with
ukraine or something along those lines
if you look at other
industrialized countries that you think
of as modern economies and peers they
are they're almost uniformly higher than
us
are they doing something better than we
are in this or we just have oh they're
yeah they are they're you know they're
like are they avoiding automation like
what that's kind of i was going like
so
what's happened here in the u.s over the
last number of years is um you had our
labor force get driven up and up by
women showing up in the workforce and
then um after that advance then it's
been going down down down for the last
number of years and years and years a
lot of the people that are getting
pushed out of the workforce are men are
are non-college educated men
and by the way that's driving a lot of
political and social
phenomena um ills i mean it's not
uh positive in most any of these
communities and and so then
uh you
have automation also that now is
speeding up
uh you have people who are
dropping out of the workforce right now
for a variety of reasons uh some of it's
health related some of it is meaning of
life related i mean this is a very very
tough time and so a lot of people are
taking a step back and if you have the
capacity to take a step back even for a
month or two
particularly by the way if you have a
job that you're
pretty confident you can get an
equivalent job at the drop of a hat you
know i mean like if if i'm in like i
always go back to x yeah like let's say
i'm a server at a restaurant or i'm a
retail clerk um am i pretty confident i
can just show up to another store or
restaurant and get a job like that right
now yes yeah of course there are wanted
signs everywhere so it's like well if i
have the capacity to take
you know four weeks off or six weeks off
and or do something why don't i do that
because i know i can just swap back into
that job
other countries
uh have
done a a better job of trying to find
fits between workers and employers there
are some countries that
have very very generous bridge and
subsidy programs where they say
look
you're losing your job because for
example of automation and this does
happen in some european countries like
we're automating your job away we're
going to be moving heaven and earth for
a while to like find you a new job we're
going to subsidize this we're going to
do that we're going to like pay for and
they they actually execute
yeah better than we do like here a
politician goes to a mic and says we're
going to do this and then just everyone
forgets about it and then you go back
and nothing happened um but some of
these countries actually are
taking workers and leading them by the
hand to like employers and being like
hey let's try and make this thing work
interesting um so
there are uh there's some trends that
are speeding up in the u.s and ai is
part of this i talked to one company
that has a labor replacing robot that
costs approximately 55 000. and replaces
one worker
um working all the time
so
never stops yeah so if you do the math
on that like that robot's gonna pay for
itself within one year yeah maybe less
probably less because they're not
working working weekends and nights
right yeah
and so
i think that robot is going to sell a
lot of units
and then when you know when you look up
and say hey where'd the jobs go i mean
people are going to go like well you
know no one wanted this job so we got
this robot
and and here it is so that was the the
second big takeaway i had um the third
was i got
reminded of some of the hazards around
uh ai leapfrogging humanity and being
unfettered in its impact and decision
making there was this russian
mathematician you could tell he was
[ __ ] brilliant it was one of those
things but he they talk math in an
accent i usually just think you're
smarter than you actually yeah that's
because i'm dumb this guy was also a
professor in a major university and the
rest of it so he was talking about um
there were some smart
conferences like really really uh
high-end yeah so the types of
conferences andrew's getting invited to
on ai are pretty for what it's for what
it's worth they're pretty cool man yeah
uh thanks
yeah
yeah you better be right you're one of
the one of the bigger thought leaders on
the topic okay keep going yeah and yeah
it's thank you for saying so uh it's
also the case that i turn down a lot of
freaking yeah yeah yes i'm saying you
get a lot of them so when you decide to
go yeah it's
a good one because most of them i just
i'm just like hey no offense if you've
invited us to a conference we get a lot
it's not personal yeah sometimes it's a
little personal but
okay done so so this uh mathematician
said something that stuck with me even
though i kind of knew this stuff already
he was like hey if you have an ai
that let's say is like a little smarter
than a human
um maybe maybe it's genius level maybe
of like a human genius level ai but then
it can self-replicate itself like a
thousand or a million times over and so
then you have a million genius level
intellects working on something
simultaneously and it can actually line
itself up so that it's all able to to
conjoin
um so
you you reflect on that for a moment
you're like oh my gosh then you can
really
it was like above average intelligence
yeah he's like he's like he doesn't even
need to be like you you don't need like
one
like super genius level ai if you have
even like a fairly intelligent ai that
you can then replicate a thousand or a
million times over and because of the
way it's wired it can actually have
those
um
those units all working in tandem in
concert so that they're
speeding each other up or
speeding up the entire process and then
it really dawns on you for a moment
you're like oh wait a minute that this
thing really
is going to
uh transform a lot of what we think of
as work
so this particular mathematician there
were a number of things that a lot of
smart people said at this conference but
they were like hey
uh
right now the
natural
state of affairs is going to lead the
rewards to end up being
held in the hands of a small number of
firms or individuals
and the level of public safeguards are
kind of lacking
and so we should be pursuing some kind
of manhattan project
government-led
uh initiative to try and keep ai from
doing
negative things
as it's getting stronger and more
powerful
and i heard this from a number of people
there and they were all correct and then
i thought to myself oh gosh like where
is our government on this
um and our government is not exactly
you know
uh
at the
vanguard of trying to figure out what's
happening in these labs uh or in these
firms um so
that reminded me of some of the
large-scale issues that we're facing
another person spoke about how
there are a couple dozen countries that
already are investing in ai
weapon systems
that
are going to naturally want to make
decisions as quickly as possible because
you have to consult a human it slows you
down
so
one of the proposals is for countries to
come together and adopt a treaty that
says hey
a human has to decide when to use lethal
force it's not just that an autonomous
system goes well you're in the wrong
place like you dead
that sort of thing um but he said that
the natural impulse for countries is
going to be for speed and efficiency and
not trying to have a human somewhere in
that lane right security guards like
guarding a border of some sort or a
drone or something like that where maybe
it's got some humanity
baked into its code but it's going to
shoot to kill when it sees a warm body
or whatever it is right is that kind of
what we're talking about especially some
of the countries that are bootstrapping
that they're just like it kills anything
that moves right yeah and then you have
asymmetrical
non-country actors so there's an
international world order that right now
is not exactly humming right you know
you have different factions
uh and then you have non-state actors
and
whatever protocol you come up with so
right now the countries can't even agree
on how to use ai right militarily and
then if you have non-state actors or
even terrorist organizations getting a
hold of some of these things then of
course
they're going to be no rules so you you
start reflecting on what this is going
to mean over time you're like oh
my gosh
uh so so those were some of the things
that i took away and i will say that
this conference was very very positive
there were people that were trying to
solve these problems they were like look
let's come together and and
um get in front of this stuff
and so i don't want to be
super pessimistic in part because
uh you know like it was a conference
around solutions but a lot of very smart
people were very concerned about the
natural trend yeah and we have been for
a while um
you ever read i used to read this blog
wait but why
yeah yeah by tim urban and he's done he
is one on elon musk
a while ago was really good um but he
did another one on ai
and basically the school of thought at
least then i think it's still the case
is that
um
so there's like
three forms of ai there's
can do one task better than a human
being that's like when we play that
computer in chess or we uh
play
you know someone uh
gps i guess giving you directions faster
or something like that one task though
then there's it can do every task it's
as smart as a human being and then
we haven't gotten there yet and the
third one is it's smarter than a human
being and in his uh the the school of
thought is that
we're at stage one right now we know
it's not an if but it's a when we'll get
to stage two when the computer is as
smart as human being
but we don't know we don't know when
that is but we do know that once we hit
two we'll essentially immediately hit
three
because as soon as as soon as it has the
capacity to improve itself then it could
improve itself to be smart enough yeah
and then infinite yeah yeah
exponentially so yeah and then the
analogy he used in this blog post was
that it'd be like um we will be like a
monkey looking at a skyscraper like well
no
it's a skyscraper or we'll know like
it's a big object
we'll know it's got shapes and forms and
maybe people going in and out we can see
activities but we won't fundamentally
understand what that
skyscraper is
which is
terrifying i think an ai in general i
don't know it's like a next stage of
human evolution or evolution i guess
it's not human anymore
[Music]
you